we need two Undercovers at the DeKalb
Street warehouse party uh Boyle you're
already in costume as Joy Behar I'm
Mario Batali okay and Santiago you go
with them yes sir
damn it Santiago I know that you hate
Halloween but stick with me and I
promise you you will love it
can you magically make everyone kind
sober and fully dressed kind sober and
fully dressed good news everyone we
found the name of Santiago's sex tape
[Music]
what is all this
no I think Halloween is for jerks well
this Halloween I was the jerk I'm sorry
about tonight
I'm sorry about tonight we found the
title for Santiago's follow-up sex tape
I'm sorry I couldn't convince you to
love Halloween it's not your fault I was
terrible it's not your fault I was
terrible is also one of your sex tapes
Halloween is unbearable but it was
slightly less unbearable with you don't
dude this is so cool shoot around
corners I love guns I'm gonna make such
a good dad not even gonna touch that the
Amy Santiago story the linoleum awaits
my dear
[Music]
I know undercover than starting to get
real nervous about this contest you need
to see a therapist it stands this way
how did you manage to step on both of my
feet at the same time I'm horrible at
this one can we stop I'm horrible at
this I know I know
title of my sex tape yeah well done
title of my sex tape oh my god the
captain could really bring this thing
how did you get so amazing at dancing
take focus I found a back stairway over
here and spin hey got you drink
champagne mixed with thirty-year-old
scotch and top-shelf tequila captain
said a two-drink maximum at set a price
limit smart hmm oh god it's horrible
yeah shouldn't have added the olive
juice ooh
hey so listen the thing I said to you
before I went undercover about how I
wish something had happened between us
romantically that wasn't nothing that
was real what are you saying I know that
you're with teddy I'm not trying to
change that and I get their stuff I
can't control but this morning I told
you that I didn't mean any of it and
that was a lie I just don't want to hold
anything back well thank you for saying
that just as long as we're clear that
I'm with someone and nothing is gonna
happen I'm with someone nothing's gonna
happen Amy your sex tape he's back fine
I'll get my stuff but this better not
bite me in the ass better not bite me in
the ass name your sex tape but seriously
thank you so much for your help
Santiago yes before you go
both of you requested to have this
Saturday off but I need one of you to
work I can take that shift or last time
you worked a Saturday you watch the
cartoons the entire time well that's
when you're on work this out and get
back to me
sorry I can't reschedule I have tickets
to a TED talk on power poses and getting
what you want by using your body Oh
hope it doesn't get too sexual oh I hope
it doesn't get too sexual title your sex
tape but seriously what is taking so
long also the title year 16
Yeek blast of cold air coming out of
that box name of Amy's sex tape hey man
come on not cool I'm going through
something just let me have this one look
like it when I go got some coffee
great hey yeah I know that it's just us
there's a thing I wanted to say yeah
does that you why doesn't your mouth
work why doesn't your mouth work title
of our sex tape your sex tape
what No uh sorry I think feeling a
little awkward yeah me too
how do we make it not weird I know
let's just get super drunk yes great
idea pardon me ma'am could you please
bring us four kamikaze shots and four
for me as well ah I like your style see
we can do this we're back on track we're
keeping it light and breezy so we broke
a rule yeah I hope it wasn't a mistake
however wasn't a mistake
title your sex tape title of our sex
tape how do you explain this I have no
idea
I put the plaque in my office Jetta come
here come here come here baby
hell yeah thank you but turning my
office please what's up you little turds
wait what is going on we have the plaque
yeah I just got out of the venture rub
it in your faces
I just got it at the bench rub it in
your face his name of your sex tape what
we don't have any more prize we're
promised oh and one more thing they're
guilty no we are not
please do not address the jury mr.
Peralta but but one more but and you
will be in contempt one mark on your
content of your sex tape
you